-Guys, it is time for "tonight
show hashtags." Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every week
where -- What?
[ Laughter ]
-You caught me off-guard.
-Yeah. You're like,
"Go up about it"?
-Yeah.
-Or go down about it?
-Eh.
-♪ Go up about it ♪
♪ Go down about it ♪
♪ I'm gonna shout about it ♪
♪ No doubt about it ♪
♪ Uptown, downtown ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ People on the street ♪
♪ Call me on the phone ♪
♪ I'll be here alone ♪
♪ Reading all my book ♪
♪ Getting those nasty looks ♪
♪ It's just my book, my book ♪
♪ My book,
it's a Fallon book cluuuub ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Air horn blows ]
-Fallon Book Club is filmed
before a live studio audience.
-Dip it in ranch.
-Dip it!
-So, we do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys to respond to
that topic.
So, summer is in full swing.
I sent out
the hashtag #SummerBod.
-Ooh.
-Yep.
And I asked you guys to sent
a tweet, a funny, weird,
or embarrassing story
about your summer bod.
Within minutes it was a trending
topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I thought I'd share --
They're funny.
Some of my favorite #SummerBod
tweets from you guys.
This first is from
@msmcslothyface.
-Ooh. Rather.
[ Laughter ]
-She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Daniel Kaluuya movie as well.
"Nope."
-"Nope."
-This one is from
@kansasbradbury.
That's a good name.
-Kansas Bradbury?
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow!
-Wow! Wow!
-That's pretty good.
-Burn!
-Yeah.
This one's from @fitkix.
-Fitkix!
-She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow.
This one's from
@legendwt4itdary.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait for it. Wait for it.
-I love that. That might be
my favorite Twitter name.
Legendwt4itdary.
-Nice.
-Legendary.
-Legend...dary.
-Wait for it. Dary.
Dip it in ranch.
[ Laughter ]
That's our new catchphrase.
-Yeah.
-"The Tonight Show,"
dip it in ranch.
-Dip it. FBC.
-[ Southern accent ]
Dip it in ranch.
-Have some ranch. Dip it.
-[ Normal voice ] He's Southern.
[ Southern accent ]
Dip it in ranch.
[ Effeminate voice ] Or is he
like dip it in ranch.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] I don't know
what he is. Or maybe he's gruff.
-[ Deep voice ] He's both.
Dip it in ranch.
-[ Deep voice ] Deeper voice.
-Dip it in ranch!
-Yeah, I got my divorce papers
from my wife.
I took it. I dipped it in ranch.
[ Laughter ]
-And mustard sauce.
-[ Normal voice ] Alright.
This one is from
@legendwt4itdary. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Punks!
-You teens!
-Budget --
-Budget Aquaman.
-Budget Aquaman!
I didn't say it. He did, man.
We're in a book club.
-Yeah, we're reading.
-This one's from @ray00794010.
Easy to remember, right?
[ Laughter ]
How come you never tweet me,
man?
-What's your handle?
-Oh, it's very easy.
Ray0079189344. More four.
-Great.
-He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one is from @amywamy7.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow! Wow!
-That's official.
-That's funny, man.
-That's dip it in ranch
right there.
-Dip it -- Dip that --
Dip it in ranch.
-Bag of milk with hair.
-Yep.
This one's from
@daviddwwilliams. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @yitzyraven.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come on.
-Come on.
-Come on. This one's from
@go4arun22. He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a long walk,
but it's funny.
We're down to our last one.
It's from @litterickb.
He says...
Look at this photo. Whoa, boy!
There you have it, those are
our "Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.